-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
So, I don't know
if you know this,
but, recently,
researchers in Australia
named a new species of insect
after RuPaul.
It's called the Opaluma RuPaul.
Here it is.
It is colorful.
It is rainbow-hued.
It's just a good-looking bug.
And this is
really exciting news.
I found out that
I am also going to
have a new bug named after me.
Here to introduce it is
a member of
the Entomological society
of America.
Todd Conn, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
-Of course.
And, first of all, I just want
to say this is an honor.
I am thrilled to have
an insect named after me.
-You know, like we saw with
the Opaluma RuPaul,
naming new species of insects
after celebrities
helps attract attention
to our conservation efforts.
So, as an entomologist,
I'm very grateful to you
for participating.
-Well, you are very welcome.
-And with that,
I would like to introduce
our newly discovered specimen,
the Scarabaeus SethMeyers.
-Uh...huh.
-Pretty thrilling, right?
-That's the bug?
-That's your bug.
You know, our researchers
were beyond thrilled
to name this specimen
the SethMeyers
and honor you and your legacy
in late-night comedy.
-So, like, what --
Is it some kind of cockroach?
-Oh, no, no, no.
The SethMeyers is technically
a variety of dung beetle.
-A dung beetle.
-Yeah, you know what dung is,
don't you, Seth?
-Yeah, I know.
-It's [bleep]
We actually call it the
[bleep] bug around the office.
-Great.
-So, you see, the SethMeyers
is the first variety
of dung beetle that consumes
its own feces for sustenance.
In fact, due to
a special digestive enzyme,
the SethMeyers beetle
survives almost exclusively
by devouring its own feces.
-So, I guess I had
something else in mind.
-Well, you know, Seth, you don't
get to pick your insect.
We do.
-Yeah.
-Just, you know, the RuPaul bug,
you know, was colorful.
It was just more exciting.
-Oh, trust me, the SethMeyers
is very exciting.
-It is?
-You know, for example,
it constantly secretes
this runny, snot-like mucus,
which is pretty fascinating.
Plus, the SethMeyers
is famous for emitting
this noxious, rancid odor
that has never before been
observed in nature.
Do you have any idea
why that might be, Seth?
-Is it because it eats
its own feces?
-Hey! That's right.
You know, you may have
a future in entomology.
-Would I get to
pick my own insect then?
-No.
Now, one thing
I did want to add --
in order to thank you
for your help,
we've put you in
the latest issue of
"The American Entomologist,"
where we're featuring
celebrity insects.
So, here you go.
There's Daniel Craig and
his blue-eyed damselfly.
And there's you with
your dung beetle
getting ready to eat
a big bowl of feces.
-So, Daniel Craig's bug
has blue eyes.
It's very obvious
how that connects to him.
You know, I also have blue eyes.
It doesn't matter.
I guess I just
don't really see how
the dung beetle connects to me.
-You know how you do your talk
show at 12:30 a.m. every night?
-Uh-huh.
-Well, that happens to be
the exact time
the SethMeyers beetle
starts its day.
and is typically eating
its first meal,
which is, of course...
-Feces.
-Feces, yeah.
-Well, I'm happy to help
with a good cause,
and I guess I'm honored to
have this dung beetle
named after me.
-That's great.
You know, ultimately,
I hope things like this
help people see that insects --
they're living creatures,
like you and me,
and by connecting to them,
we're connecting to
a larger ecosystem
that holds us all together.
-You know,
that was beautifully put.
-Oh, my God!
[Bleep]
Did you see that?!
Oh, my good Lord!
That was one of the biggest
SethMeyers I've ever seen.
One of them
must have gotten out of the lab.
Oh, look at this [bleep]
There's SethMeyers goo
all over me.
Oh, my God!
You know, we might want to
clear out the studio,
because this place is about to
stink like SethMeyers.
-Alright, you know what?
We'll be right back.